tell all the truth but tell it slant
success in circuit lies too bright for
our and firm delight the truth superb
surprise as lightning to the children
East with explanation kind the truth
must dazzle gradually or every man be
blind of all the poems of Emily
Dickinson it's a little funny that this
one feels so direct Dickinson is known
for work that's full of ambiguity odd
manipulations in meter and rhyme images
that seem mysterious and sometimes out
of place it's poetry brimming with slant
truth in other words poetry that puts
into practice the very philosophy that
seemingly laid out here in perfect meter
and matching rhymes it strikes me as odd
that the poem which best describes this
philosophy is one in which she abandons
it on first read it appears that
Dickinson is so intent on getting her
point across that she repeats it four
times first in line one the most naked
assertion she implores tell the whole
truth but tell it indirectly then in
line two she says this another way
success in telling the truth lies in a
circuitous journey not a direct one in
lines three and four she describes the
failure of that direct approach the
surprise of direct truth is too bright
for our weak and unstable capacity for
delight it will in other words
short-circuit us and finally in lines
five through eight she hammers home the
point again using lightning as a
metaphor the apprehension of truth must
be gradual she says like a parent's
explanation of lightning to children
rather than the Lightning itself which
if looked at directly would blind the
viewer after these four phrasings
the meaning could not be more clear the
truth is something worth telling the
world but it can't be presented head-on
it must come at an oblique angle if the
writer hopes to have any chance at
success hey everybody thank you so much
for watching I really appreciate you
know what it it can't be that simple
Emily Dickinson always has something
hiding
firstly let's go back and read through
it again tell all the truth but tell it
slant right away in the first line the
one that seems the most over Dickinson
plants a seedling of ambiguity it's here
the word all does it refer to all the
truth as in the whole truth as we said
before or all the people as in tell
everyone the truth it's a small bit of
uncertainty but it opens up a crack in
the poem that foreshadows things to come
success in circuit lies things get
wobbly or in the second line in a poem
about truth the word lie sticks out like
a sore thumb the sentence invites us to
read it as reside or be found success
resides in circuitous nests but as
Professor Ashby Crowder points out the
speaker doesn't seem to realize that she
actually says circuit lies to the line
in effect containing its own
contradiction circuit is an important
image in Dickinson's work often
contrasted with circumference where
circuit means life as we know it and
circumference is the outer limit of
experience the tenuous often frightening
boundary between what human beings can
understand and infinity or truth with a
capital T Dickinson has a deeply
ambivalent relationship with
circumference at times expressing that
it's safer to remain within one circuit
at other times proclaiming my business
is circumference as she once did in the
letter here amazingly she manages to
condense that ambivalence into just four
words without losing any of its
complexity too bright for our and firm
delight the truth superb surprise the
immediate thing you notice is that the
sentence is flipped around so that the
final word can be surprised the truth is
a surprise Dickinson says one that is
too bright for our D light literally d
light an emotion that is inherently weak
and feeble she contends it's about now
when things start to fall off the rails
a little bit because if truth is a
surprise a word that originally meant an
attack without warning a surprise too
bright for us
how can anyone grab hold of it in the
first place to read
packaged it in a slant or circuitous way
the word surprise at the end of this
phrase almost starts to feel ominous
like you've gone back into the poem only
to fight as lightning to the children
East with explanation kind the truth
must dazzle gradually or every man be
blind now that we're looking at this
poem with some suspicion it's easier to
see the problems in the metaphor
Dickinson picks to elucidate her earlier
statements she equates telling slant
truth to adults easing children about
lightning except it's not the children
who are eased here according to this
slightly confusing grammar it's the
lightning does an explanation however
kind actually ease the force of
lightning it strikes me that children
equipped with feeble emotions facing a
surprise attack from something that's so
bright it will blind them have good
reason to be scared all a kind
explanation can do as Professor Gary Lee
Stoneham notes is offer a comforting but
preposterous fiction a realization
that's brought home in the phrase dazzle
gradually which sounds great with its
assonance but is ultimately oxymoronic
things can't dazzle gradually when
something dazzles like lightning it
happens all at once so where are we left
after this somewhere between the
blindness of not ever being able to see
the truth and the blindness of actually
seeing it this I think is where
Dickenson wanted to get us all along
she essentially wrote a poem that
subverts itself this is not direct like
it appears to be she knew all too well
that a kind explanation of her
philosophy just wouldn't work the poem
had to be the philosophy that feeling of
the text being destabilized from within
oscillating from meaning to the negation
of that meeting
that's Dickinson showing you the
Lightning that's Dickinson stepping out
onto the circumference glimpsing some
truth in the unstable place where
language fails and it's dazzling
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this is really the end this
time or is it yeah it is
this episode was brought to you by
Skillshare an online learning community
for creators with more than 18,000
classes and everything from graphic
design and film editing to finance and
IT security you know when I learned
Photoshop I learned it through a
mishmash of disconnected YouTube videos
and the process would have gone a lot
faster if there was a class dedicated to
teaching me everything about that
program in a systematic way
learning new skills is really valuable
to me because whenever I learn a new
skill it's like a bunch of new ideas are
suddenly unlocked in my head I think
what can I do with this and that always
helps me with writer's block a premium
membership begins around ten dollars a
month for unlimited access to all
courses but the first 500 people to sign
up using the link in the description get
their first two months for free in those
two months you could easily learn the
skills you need to start a new hobby or
business more importantly the skills you
learn will help give you ideas for what
that business or art project could be
try it out thanks guys I'll see you next
time